hey guys welcome to a video on code
Tecna toriel's my name is Matt and today
I want to talk a little bit just briefly
about this drama that's going on with
some of these other tech YouTube
channels and why should i but in why
should I talk about it let me just
explain a little quick background I
discovered engineering truth when I was
like in my first or second year of
computer science I figured I'd listen to
some see if I could get some tips same
with like the tech lead found him
thought his channel is great for sarcasm
purposes I obviously didn't take his
serious his channel seriously because
who in their right mind does and then
this guy trend black starts ragging on
him and basically exposing them which I
thought was fine yeah maybe he was a
little harsh in his videos but I don't
think he was being dishonest oh I think
that got totally glazed over though he
tried to do this this same type of video
to joshua fluke and he took it down
because he wasn't happy with it I think
Joshua fluke responded basically called
him out on pretty much every point told
him why he was wrong and pretty much
every point turned black took it down
because well I think he just lost that
battle so it was pretty funny that he
couldn't pin down that ultimate
doppelganger of the tech channels
Joshua fluke that's a compliment by the
way being a doppelganger in my book is a
good thing if someone can't pin you down
on anything well I don't know I'm just
riffing here I don't know if that's
necessarily good it could be bad alright
so I want to dive into this this is
really hot right now apparently Matt
Tran the engineer drew sky doxed trend
black what's to really see let's just
google it here let's see what it comes
up trend black verse Matt Tran alright
let's let's just see what pops up so
this is a pretty hot thing right now and
here's the big takeaway all right I'm
just gonna be honest here it doesn't
matter this means nothing
this is always time like the reason I
started following these channels to
begin with is because I wanted to get
better at the skills I was studying and
now it's just turned into Tiger king
drama the only thing you can probably
learn from it is what not to do so
really anything else to say and I don't
think there is
it's don't waste your time that's the
point if you're interested in tech and
careers and you're a real engineer or a
real person that actually wants to get
stuff done and actually wants to build
stuff it actually wants to be known for
their work you should not be paying
attention to this drama it's just a
waste of time if you're studying your
work you shouldn't be doing this I
understand that everybody needs a little
downtime needs a little Netflix time you
can maybe slip this drama in in that
downtime because that's what it is it's
nothing related to work it's nothing
useful for anybody it's just what I call
Tiger King drama so do these channels
need to be stopped I don't know I don't
really care him to be honest I don't
think well there are some good things
here I understand that trend Black's
motive is is overall from what I can
tell a positive motive he seems to want
there to not be a bunch of false
information out there about what the job
markets like so he's exposing people
that are giving bad information now at
least that's its goal but is he taking
it too far I don't for each individual
to decide ok well that's really all I
got I just wanted to say my piece and
I'm gonna get back to it peace out guys
Hey look
right on cue there's my phone I'll stop
the video goodbye don't forget to Like
and subscribe